>> Sean: THE MEDIA MOB IS CAUGHT
SPREADING ANOTHER ROUND OF FAKE
NEWS.
REMEMBER IN THE RECKLESS
COVERAGE LAST SUMMER, THEY
CLEARED OUT PROTESTORS IN D.C.
DONALD TRUMP WAS ACCUSED OF
REMOVING PROTESTORS FOR A
A PHOTO-OP.
IT TURNS OUT THAT NARRATIVE WAS
A COMPLETE LIE.
TRUMP AND RUSSIA WAS A LIE.
UKRAINE QUID PRO QUO THAT WAS
JOE.
THAT WAS NOT DONALD TRUMP.
WE WERE MISLED ABOUT THE ORIGINS
OF COVID-19 AND THE WUHAN LAB.
THAT THE LEFT WING MEDIA LIED
ABOUT THAT AND SAID MOST PEOPLE
IT'S AMAZING PEOPLE GUILTY OF
SPREADING LIES AND HOAXES, THEY
ARE THE ONES OUT THERE ACCUSING
EVERYONE ELSE OF BEING GUILTY OF
THAT WHICH THEY ARE PRACTICING
DAILY.
TONIGHT NEW INFORMATION.
WATCH DOG REPORT FINDING THAT
PARK POLICE DID NOT CLEAR
DEMONSTRATORS FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP BUT TO INSTALL ANTI-SCALE
FENCING IN RESPONSE TO ATTACKS
ON FEDERAL PROPERTY.
LISTEN TO THE PAIN OF FAKE NEWS
REPORTER FROM MSNBC HAVING TO
DELIVER THE NEWS TO CHUCKIE TOD.
>> THE NARRATIVE TOOK HOLD.
IT WAS WIDELY REPORTED ACROSS
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA THAT BARR
ORDERED THIS TO CLEAR THE PARK
FOR TRUMP.
THAT'S NOT WHAT HAPPENED
ACCORDING TO THIS REPORT.
>> THE PARK WAS ORDERED CLEARED.
TRUMP WANTED TO GO BUT THE TWO
WERE NOT CONNECTED.
>> Sean: REMEMBER THESE FAKE
NEWS HEADLINES LAST SUMMER?
PEACEFUL PROTESTORS TEAR GASSED
TO CLEAR THE WAY FOR TRUMP
CHURCH PHOTO-OP.
DID THEY GET ANYTHING RIGHT?
HERE TO REACT IS THE HOST OF THE
NUMBER 1 SHOW SUNDAY NIGHT HERE
ON THE FOX NEWS CHALLENGE.
LIFE, LIBERTY AND LEVIN.
THIS NEW BOOK IS COMING OUT IN
A COUPLE OF WEEKS.
I HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO READ
A NUMBER OF THE CHAPTERS.
IT PROVIDES THE ROAD MAP TO SAVE
THIS COUNTRY.
THAT'S THAT PROFOUND.
MARK LEVIN.
A LOT OF GROUND FOR YOU TO
COVER.
CONGRATS ON THE BOOK.
>> THANK YOU.
YOU ARE VERY, VERY KIND.
I NEED TO SPEND MY 4 MINUTES AND
37 SECONDS ON THIS BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT.
THE MEDIA SPENT 2 OR 3 WEEKS
LYING ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
WHAT SHOULD WE EXPECT FROM THE
AMERICAN MEDIA?
THAT'S THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY ARE DRESSED UP AS
JOURNALISTS WHETHER IT'S CNN OR
MSNBC.
YOU SAW CHUCK TODD WHO HAS AN IQ
OF A FIFTH GRADER.
DONALD TRUMP IS THE MOST ABUSED
PRESIDENT IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS HERE.
I HAVE THE REPORT.
THEY SAID PROTESTS BEGAN AROUND
LAFAYETTE PARK ON MAY 30 IN
2020.
49 U.S. PARK POLICE WERE
INJURED.
OVER 50 SECRET SERVICE WERE
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS FAMILY HAD
TO BEING TAKEN TO THE NUCLEAR
BUNKER.
THEY HAD TO CLEAR THE WAY OUT TO
GET IN NON-CLIMBING FENCES.
A HISTORIC CHURCH WAS BURNED AND
THESE CLOWNS INCLUDING TODD AND
HIS NETWORK TALK ABOUT
A PEACEFUL PROTEST.
THERE IS THE INSURRECTION, BABY!
SHOULD BE WE SURPRISED AT THE
MEDIA?
NO, DURING THE HOLCAST LED BY
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" THEY
COVERED UP THE HOLOCAUST.
LET'S GO DOWN MEMORY LANE.
JOE BIDEN ALWAYS THE AMBULANCE
CHASER.
IT TRUMPS TWEETS YOU USED THE
AMERICAN MILITARY AGAINST THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
LIAR!
JOE BIDEN THE NEXT DAY.
100,000 AMERICANS DIED BECAUSE
OF HIS INCOMPETENT LEADERSHIP
THIS PRESIDENT SCOFFED.
LIAR!
KAMALA HARRIS, DONALD TRUMP TEAR
GASSED PEACEFUL PROTESTORS FOR
A PHOTO-OP.
LIAR.
THE NEXT DAY, SAME THING.
PELOSI THE SAME THING.
SCHIFF THE SAME THING.
THE GREAT GENERAL MATTIS.
I SWORE TO SUPPORT THE
CONSTITUTION.
NEVER DID I DREAM THAT TROOPS
WOULD BE ORDERED TO VIOLATE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS OF FELLOW
CENTERS FOR A BIZARRE PHOTO-OP
FOR THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
LIAR.
GENERAL MARK DEMPSEY IN AN OBAMA
HAT.
IT GOES ON AND ON.
THE "WASHINGTON POST" AND THE
"NEW YORK TIMES."
THIS STORY THAT SHOWS THEM ALL
TO BE LIARS.
30 SECONDS AND GO ON TO
TOMORROW.
AS YOU POINTED OUT EARLIER,
SEAN, THEY LIED ABOUT SO MANY
CONSPIRACY THEORIES ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP IT'S AWFUL.
I WANT TO TAKE THE REMAINING 2
MINUTE AND 17 SECONDS I HAVE TO
SAY THIS IN ALL SERIOUSNESS.
JOE BIDEN BECAUSE OF WHAT HE'S
DONE WITH THE PIPELINE TO
RUSSIA, WHAT HE IS DOING WITH
TIKTOK AND OTHERS IN COMMUNIST
CHINA.
JOE BIDEN WILL GET US IN A WAR.
HE WANTS TO SPEND 6 TRILLION
DOLLARS.
HE IS OUT OF HIS MIND.
BUT HE WANTS TO KEEP FLAT
DEFENSE SPENDING WHEN CHINA IS
OUT OF CONTROL AND THEY ARE
PREPARING TO INVADE TAIWAN.
THAT'S NUMBER 1 AM NUMBER 2, JOE
BIDEN IS GOING TO CREATE NOT
A RECESSION BUT AT SOME POINT
A DEPRESSION.
MAYBE NOT ON HIS WATCH BUT HE IS
DRAGGING US DOWN THAT PATH.
UNPRECEDENTED INFLATION.
THAT MEANS THE VALUE OF THE
CURRENCY GOES DOWN AND THE
VALUABLE OF YOUR PAYCHECK AND
PENSION GOES DOWN.
BUT PRICES GO WAY UP.
WE SAW THIS EARLIER IN THE
REAGAN ADMINISTRATION.
TWO TOUGH YEARS TO KILL OFF
INFLATION WANT JOE BIDEN HAS
TAKEN THE TRUMP RECOVERY AND
TURNING IT IT INTO THE HERBERT
HOOVER AND ROOSEVELT DEPRESSION.
YOU BETTER KEEP AN EYE ON THIS
GUY, FOLKS.
IT'S NOT THAT HE IS OUT OF HIS
MIND.
HE IS OUT OF HIS LEAGUE.
THAT'S IT.
>> Sean: AMERICA